foreign
[Music]
hi everyone I'm Priyanka and I'm the
co-founder and CEO of Evie and really
excited to be talking to you today about
the vaginal microbiome and how it
relates to female health
I decided to start Evie after realizing
a couple of the crazy facts that are
here on the slide today one was that
women weren't required to be in clinical
research in the U.S until
1993. and to this day women are on
average diagnosed four years later than
men across over 770 diseases
and what this says to me is that we have
a huge data Gap when it comes to our
understanding of the female body
as uh the NIH associate director uh
Janine Austin Clayton said we literally
know less about every aspect of female
biology compared to male biology and
that's exactly what we're trying to
solve here at Evie
we're on a mission to radically reinvent
how we understand and treat the female
body specifically by discovering and
leveraging female specific biomarkers
and the first set of biomarkers that
we're focused on is the what's going on
in the vaginal microbiome and usually
when I say that I get one of two
questions either what is the vaginal
microbiome or why is that where we're
starting given that we're at a
microbiology conference hopefully most
people here have at least heard of the
vaginal microbiome but I figured that
I'd give us a little bit of a start
by just explaining a very oversimplified
101 on what it is and why it matters
so what you see here on the slide is my
very accurate depiction of what the
vaginal microbiome looks like but if you
think about it you know like any
microbiome the vaginal microbiome is a
community of bacteria fungi viruses and
other microbes that live in a certain
part of our bodies right just like the
microbiome that lives in our gut or in
our mouth or on our skin turns out we
also have one in our vaginas and what's
really interesting is that what we've
seen over time as we've started to
research the vaginal microbiome is that
much like many of the other microbiomes
that we are also learning about it looks
like they're doing a lot more than just
kind of hanging out in the vagina right
and if you think about the vagina as
kind of the structural connection
between the outside world which is full
of lots of different microbes and
pathogens and then on the other side
some of our most important internal
reproductive organs what we're starting
to learn is that we've essentially
co-evolved with this community of
microbes that live in the vagina and
play what I would call almost like a
local immune system role in protecting
our reproductive system from a lot of
the pathogens out in the outside world
and the way that this works is when your
vaginal microbiome is in an optimal
State it's dominated by protective
microbes the most common of which are
lactobacillus and those protective
microbes are producing lactic acid and
making the vaginal environment acidic
which makes it hard for these disruptive
microbes that might get into your
vaginal microbiome to actually Thrive
survive or take up space on the vaginal
wall
but you know I always say God forbid
women live their lives
um and you know you have sex with
someone new you sit in your swimsuit for
too long your period lasts a long time
all of those things might increase the
amount of uh or sorry increase the pH
which can then make it a more hospitable
environment for pathogens to thrive
replicate survive Etc and as people with
vaginas the way that we actually
experience this is those infections that
we are all too familiar with right
bacterial vaginosis for current yeast
infections recurrent UTIs
Etc but this breakdown in the vaginal
environment is not just leading to these
extremely frustrating infections it
turns out that that without that
protective dominance right that
dominance of microbes that are keeping
these disruptive microbes out what we
start to see is also an association with
a variety of other female Health
outcomes right IVF failure preterm birth
STI acquisition cervical cancer
progression and more
and what I'm talking about here right
this breakdown in the protective nature
of the vaginal microbiome this isn't a
niche problem it turns out that at any
given time almost 30 percent of people
with vaginas have a dysbiotic vaginal
microbiome and in the U.S vaginal
discharge is the most common reason that
women seek Health Care advice so this is
an extremely prevalent condition
it's also extremely frustrating right
most of the women who go into the
doctor's office with symptoms and get
treatment end up recurring their
symptoms come back and they're unable to
kind of get back to that protective
micro dominant vaginal environment
and on top of that we're starting to see
that this breakdown in the vaginal
environment can then have huge
implications on other female Health
outcomes like I mentioned earlier all of
which are costing the system great
amounts of money as well so what we're
starting to see is that these vaginal
infections are not just prevalent
they're not just frustrating it's that
they're also extremely expensive to the
system
and what's so incredibly frustrating to
me as a person with a vagina is that
bacterial vaginosis is still so
misunderstood by the Health Care system
today even though it is so prevalent so
frustrating and so expensive our
clinical definition of bacterial
vaginosis is still just an overgrowth of
bacteria and our clinical definition
hasn't changed since we were able to
actually use sequencing technology to
look at what the microbiome actually
looks like that means that we haven't
actually adjusted our clinical diagnosis
practices or treatments since we
actually could see what was going on
but thankfully as all of you probably
know very well there's a lot more to the
picture than what we do in the clinic
today and over the past couple of
decades a lot of incredible researchers
have been using these newer Technologies
to illuminate what's actually happening
in the microbiome when someone has BB
and using these much higher Fidelity
Technologies to look at the microbiome
what we're starting to see is that in
order to actually help someone with BV
it's going to require much more holistic
precise and preventative care in order
to actually get someone back to an
optimal vaginal environment and that's
obviously what we're hoping to power
with what we're building heavy
our first product that we launched in
July of 2021 so just over a year ago is
an at-home vaginal microbiome test that
allows anyone with a vagina to learn
everything that's going on in her
vaginal ecosystem why it matters and
then also what she can do about it which
really empowers every person with a
vagina to build a much stronger
understanding of their vaginal Health
understand the research behind what we
know and what we don't know about the
vaginal microbiome and feel empowered
with the information and action that
they can take to better understand how
the vaginal microbiome relates to their
overall health goals
and we're so lucky to be doing this in
partnership with some of some incredible
leaders across the clinical and research
side of the spectrum who've been working
on the vaginal microbiome both with
patients in the clinic as well as in the
research lab so that we can come up with
much better diagnoses and treatments
and alongside our uh incredible board
we've really been thinking about uh the
way we can leverage our platform in a
few different ways
first is really focused on our members
and patients today thinking about how
can we actually provide every person
with a vagina with a personalized
understanding of their vaginal
microbiome and how it relates to their
overall health so giving them a full
picture of what's going on and how
research might show that that's related
to other things in their life that they
care about
we've also been really focused on
providing people with a full picture
into the data and directing people
directly to the research we always say
that it's our job to treat our members
like they're smart enough to understand
the nuances of the science that we're
presenting them with and it makes me
laugh thinking back you know a year ago
we had many people telling us that you
know women can't handle this information
they're going to be hysteric you can't
give this information to them and
obviously what we found is that by
giving people information on their own
bodies it's actually the opposite it's
extremely calming it's extremely
empowering to feel like you actually
understand what's going on in your body
how your behaviors are shifting it and
we've seen that kind of Empower a lot
more people to have more productive
conversations with their partners and
their doctors over time
and along the way we've been extremely
focused on also demystifying and
destigmatizing vaginal Health as I said
earlier these are truly some of the most
common problems that women deal with and
yet there are also problems that so many
of us feel like we have to go through
alone due to the incredible stigma shame
and taboo that surrounds them and we're
very much trying to build educational
platforms to meet people one-on-one to
meet them in our individual communities
as well as at scale through Tick Tock
and our blog to make sure that every
person with a vagina has access to
scientifically sound education about
vaginal health
and what's been so exciting about kind
of building this platform with the
science and the data and bringing
consumers along the way is that we've
also been able to start doing improving
on our clinical understanding of these
conditions and with our platform today
only one year in what we're starting to
find is that there are so many
opportunities to create much much better
better clinical applications that are
more precise and holistic right so
whether that means coming up with much
more individualized definitions of
health and disease that are stratifying
what health and disease look like in
different populations or coming up with
more tailored treatment status
strategies based on these much more
specific uh stratifications and then
also thinking about biomarkers for a lot
of these broader female Health outcomes
that I measured mentioned earlier
and what's been really exciting to see
is that there is actually huge value in
looking at the microbiome at a much
higher Fidelity than we had before
what I'm showing you here is some of our
real data where you can see on the left
side
a microbe that is currently considered a
pathogen in the vaginal microbiome and
what you're seeing here is that there is
actually a huge variation in the genetic
composition here and what we're seeing
is that variation is also associated
with the difference in symptoms and
we're really excited to start diving
into what actually makes these different
and can we actually have a much more
granular understanding of what that
pathogen or disease State actually looks
like
and then on the right side what you're
seeing is a microbe that is currently
classified as healthy so when someone
would go to the doctor would likely not
be considered a pathogen and again what
we're seeing is huge variation that is
also associated with large variation in
symptoms and again we're really excited
to dive in and be able to provide people
with much more specific information that
can help them understand uh their
personal disease state
and we're really excited to be doing a
lot of This research in partnership with
both academic and clinical leaders
across the Spectrum from thinking about
metabolomics to thinking about how the
overall communities interact with each
other
um all the way down into the clinic
where we're working directly with
doctors to think about uh innovating on
and deploying care Pathways that are
much more specific to the data that
they're seeing for an individual patient
but as we always say this problem is
massive right women and people with
vaginas deserve so much better than the
care that we're given for these
extremely common and extremely
frustrating conditions but this is not a
problem that we can solve alone
and we're really excited to be building
the future of female Health alongside
women and people with vaginas who want
to learn more about their own vaginal
Health find Community share their
stories also alongside clinicians who
are excited about using more precise and
personalized information for their own
patients and then lastly with research
institutions and scientists who are
interested in leveraging Evie's platform
to help us in our mission of improving
improving female Health outcomes
so we hope that we're able to work with
some of you we're so grateful for your
support and listening into this
um and excited to hopefully connect with
people afterwards you can reach out to
me at Priyanka evvy.com or check out
Evie at our website at evie.com but
thank you so much and excited to connect